if we go [__] it's Friday
wash your [__] buff the [__]
Oh Joey where the [__] you been I've
been under the weather for a few days
people but guess what
I took my theraflu my vitamin C I did my
CBD all I smoked a joint and Here I am
I'm [__] back [__] 11
o'clock jr. e today Joe Rogan experience
why go to a festival when you got the
[__] savages right here for you
beside that it's a beautiful day to be
alive is the last week of October
trigger treating like a [__] for
joints and [__] edibles but I got a
big day today Junior e a little work out
I gotta go take them my child
trick-or-treating that's the [__]
trunk retreat and we got a recital a
ballet recital and we go back to a
different trunk-or-treat
then tomorrow I got parties I got
tomorrow night the ice house but it's
[__] sold out already so I don't know
what to tell you [__] the most
important thing is that we're here and
with we're and we're gonna go out there
and spread some [__] love today and if
nobody wants love then we're gonna have
to give it to him straight and they're
gonna have to suck our [__] ballsack
because we ain't [__] around no more
it's November you guys something 250
days from [__] Christmas
that's it [__] it's elbows and
[__] it's Friday [__]
it's gonna be a beautiful day we got
some classic orgy from perennial and we
got another container this [__] debt
for my man be real look out for that
podcast I did the smoke box last week
ready to [__] rock and I'm happy
you're here we had a good weekend on the
podcast beside the [__] cold and
whatever the Vertigo in my ear
it was a great week I'm saying dealing
with [__]
it was the ralphing memorial Monday I
didn't go I'd rather not remember him
like that what a bunch of [__] he's
an arse but everything else is beautiful
no everything remains the same
[__] get up grab your balls cuz
ain't nobody gonna give you get today
and then gonna give you dick next week
either you gotta get up [__] in
the world oh no you dick
write your goals do your twenty two
push-ups a nice protein [__] smoothie
a shade whatever you want to go and get
out there look about the [__] in the
iron telling somebody sucking my dick
tonight you understand me but whatever
if they don't suck it at least to got
you out of the [__] house like I say
I beside that listen you're young you
got the world by the balls me I'm an old
[__] goat I'm just waiting somewhere
I just dried pumpkins we can go on to
the next [__] level you follow me but
anyway who gives a [__] Joey it's time
for the [__] grain of green you
follow me that's it it's time for the
grain of me
if you ain't throwing Heat like that you
ain't [__] throwing
there's no vapor pens there's no haha
you [__] little half of mooks with
you huh I want a micro dose get the [__]
out of my face
if you ain't smoking out of the savage
to smoking this [__] you're missing the
[__] point you follow everybody wants
to take the sugar there's no shortcuts
this is it this as good as it gets
[__] after that buddy hunt them
you got to bring a blowtorch in a snort
call but do [__] gorilla biscuits
this is it
like I said November 8 next week two
weeks whatever it'll be ten years since
I did a line of coke listen I'm not
happy what I'm trying to tell you
[__] is that if I'm a loser and
I could beat that [__] you guys got this
[__] beat but I'm happy I beat it never
mind the podcast my wife my child my
friendships I'd beat that [__] which is
one of the toughest things but then
again it was this easiest part cuz I was
ready to go once you you ain't gonna
stop - you ready to go that's the other
thing
thunk thunk-thunk don't let me kid you
when you're ready to [__] go you'll
stop when I was 26 I couldn't stop I
just want to eat [__] and [__]
snort poking it is what it is but you
grow up then you see what's important in
life and that's today listen again I
haven't stopped I was 40 [__] 4 so I
could have been [__] dead by now but
I couldn't do it without you guys
because me doing these podcasts and
stuff made me walk the walk
that's the month AEA listen doing these
things I got to walk the walk for you
guys cuz I might talk [__] do you guys
have fun not walking the walk so I
appreciate you [__] doing this
I'm looking out for me like I told you a
thousand times right you [__]
I got nothing so I know this come on in
so I don't even have to young-sam but
beside that listen let's move another
ball and I'll let you get back to with
it's Friday it's paid they super mean
kit they whatever the [__] you call it I
hope it works out for you cuz you know I
love you [__] without you
listen and always remember what a church
[__] we
down to anybody you found that's a
beautiful thing about the church we
don't back down the [__] nope I don't
give a [__] I don't give a [__] and I
haven't given a [__] for 20 years you
follow me so we don't back down from
nobody we keep going straight and
[__] they want to listen I'm with you
with you're with me and they want to be
with us but they have to suck that
victories got to work for this [__]
and that's what uncle Joey wants to see
the one there's like sixth grade math
class but listen I know join my family
for a little [__] breakfast then I
gotta drive my daughter to school in the
day begins I got your mother [__]
don't forget next week Omaha Nebraska
the funny bone and the week after that
the New York Comedy Festival Gotham
comedy club with my men
Dean Dell Rizzy you know uncle Joey
loves you you know I'm not even [__]
bullshitting or whatever it's straight
to the [__] hot like deal
oh yeah been done and we cannot say they
didn't get my language a brothel pool a
wire you see they don't pop bottle
anyway I don't know what the [__] I said
I'm stoned I love your [__]
have a great weekend keep your eyes open
or you're simply playable while you're
there with your little buddies let them
hahahaha and you keep your [__] eyes
open you watch the [__] door watch
the window why is that guy moving that
way the whole [__] thing all right
promise me that done I love you
[__] have a great weekend stay
safe I see 11 a.m. today on JRE I can't
[__] wait